what's up buddy
hey um so
i'm
still pretty fresh out of a longer-term
relationship and uh it was actually you
had given me the advice to get out of it
a couple months ago and
doing the work on myself
have options
but i
want to make sure i cement the abundance
or spin plates mindset rather than the
one itis thing because i know i'm
susceptible to that because of
conditioning and whatnot and if you guys
had any tips on that
what
happened on the last call like what did
you call in for you said you had a bad
relationship
um
i was doing i vaguely remember yeah i
was in the distance thing and you
a long-distance relationship yes
okay all right okay so you moved away
from that and and your question now is
how do you avoid one-itis or
how do i just get rid of that mindset
because i know it's conditional scarcity
mindset so i mean usually the reason why
people have oneidas or an unhealthy
attachment to one check is one they're
not spinning plates they're just dating
one check okay two they don't have a
very high opinion of themselves either
either their smv isn't at its peak or
it's not high enough towards its peak
that you feel confident right because
you know what you're worth as a guy when
you get up in the morning you look in
the shower
you know you look in the mirror you look
at your bank account you look at what
you drive you know you look at your
social media following and you know
who's all engaging like you know what
your worth is right so those are the
main contributing factors so if you can
fix those by having a more abundance
lifestyle a bunch of women you know you
max out your smv have some confidence
about yourself you're not gonna tolerate
let's hey matt let's do a long distance
relationship you're going to be like
nope um i'm good you know if you want to
come visit and we can hang out then you
know i'll do that but i'm not going to
be in a relationship with you
right because you've got other options
because your smb's higher because you're
more confident sort of thing you guys
try my mod
yeah i'll mention something on the
abundance mindset because kind of like
we were talking
earlier there's a whole fake until you
make it type mentality which i agree if
you have like nowhere else to go but
once you're already kind of getting
things together you should probably drop
the whole faker to make it moniker and
actually just be that person so the
abundance mindset it applies in all
areas of your life uh
when you start having abundance in one
area it often spills over into other
areas too but as far as the girl things
really just got to get out there rich
has mentioned many times it's a skill
set you need to develop and then as soon
as you start getting some wins and it
might take a bit to get going first you
might get some matches then you'll get
some numbers then you'll get dates set
then you'll get girls to actually show
up on dates and not flake then you've
got girls to be pleasant on dates then
you'll pull to the house and then
you get all that together like all the
different steps in the process and then
you start streamlining it and eventually
you just like all right i got this down
and
like rich mentioned little things that
come up like i'll get a text message and
and uh well i was in new york last
weekend too a lot of girls will say in
their profile if you live more than like
five miles away don't bother because
it's gonna be it's gonna be a hundred
dollar uber each way and i kind of do
the same thing like you learn how to
qualify these girls and disqualify them
as fast as possible but for the
abundance mindset you have to realize
like literally there's so many girls out
there and there's so many guys that
aren't playing the game or they've taken
themselves out of the game and
uh as rich was mentioned to the last
caller you know you got to kind of look
around and and assess yourself i re like
i wake up in the morning i look in the
mirror you know i try to have a good
conversation myself but and some and
sometimes we're harder on ourselves than
anyone else externally is but then i
won't have the area you have to do it
yeah but then i walk through the airport
and i'm like no i'm good like i i i have
got it going on like i i'm all right um
because yeah because you know i get hard
on myself sometimes too but yeah your
environment going on right you're like
absolutely
matt how old are you dude
21
oh dude
you know
well no i don't mean like i don't mean
like you need to be out there you should
be having a 100 woman harem you know
throwing your dick and everything but
it's you got time right like you got so
much time dude like building up your smv
going and learning about it yeah it's i
don't even like the term abundance
mindset because it's it's not something
that comes through sheer
will or sheer you know thinking
differently it comes through experience
you know confidence is derived from
confidence so once you put up some wins
and you've stacked some things together
and the thing is the great thing about
success is that it grows exponentially
so you know when you start getting
smaller wins they get bigger and bigger
and bigger and more frequent um so you
know
it's something that
you're never going to completely
override blueprint conditioning right
because it's because we get blue pill
conditioned when we're at our youngest
and when our brains are most like
sponges and we're never going to
completely unlearn those behaviors but
eventually you know you put enough reps
in and you put enough time in you have
enough success and enough wins it's very
very easy to sort of quell any sort of
you know desires to want to slide back
into any sort of one-nighters or
anything like that but also you know
think about the stories that you tell
yourself and the things that you
um
sort of manifest in your day-to-day life
like oh well like i got to get past this
one item versus i don't have one itis
you know i said something to irishman a
couple weeks ago
and you know it was like i'm never gonna
have one is for a girl ever again
because i know what i know now and i
have enough success
you know knocked down enough where i'm
gonna be fine no matter what happens
um and that's something that is just a
complete honest assessment of where i am
in my life so um
be conscious of all those but also be
aware of like where you are in your
journey and like how you're just
starting out let me just add something
else to that too because i was just
punching some numbers in my calculator
so you said you're 21 right
yeah you have a do you have a plan to
make your first million by the time
you're 30
um yeah i work for my family's
not-for-profit and i'm going to i'm
working on scaling it up with them right
now um to try and get it to a really
efficient place how's that going for you
uh it's going really well um how much
money did you make last year
i i'm graduating college this year i'm
working part-time while i'm in college
so i mean it's not going really well
then right like you like you have an
idea you have a plan but you're not
actually starting to accumulate the
wealth so the point that i'm just making
here though is that you're putting a lot
of like an awful lot of bandwidth in
like how do i get the girls and keep the
girls and you know not fall into the bad
habits that i had before but
you know with some quick calculations
you need to make 304 dollars and 44
cents a day to have a million dollars by
the time you're 30.
and that's a lot more
useful use of your time resources and
energy to try to figure out
than getting the girls right i'm not
saying don't figure out the girl part
right like do it obviously but
there's more important questions out
there to ask yourself because as you get
older and as you deal with more women
and you see what they're made of and
you know like you just grasp an
understanding you just become less
impressed with them and they're not that
special you don't pedal you know
pedestalize them i'm not saying it's you
know like women aren't useful like women
can be useful in a man's life right
obviously [ __ ] clear i mean clear as
they people know that watching this but
they also know that you know
it's an awful uh use of your time to
spend so much your brainpower asking
questions like that when there's better
things that you could be doing with that
you see what i'm saying though right
yeah i do yeah i actually started um mma
recently and i've been putting a lot of
time into that so that's yeah do that
you know
work on your combat skills women love a
man that can be lethal right
have you ever have you ever competed
uh no no i'm pretty new to it still uh
like a month or so so yeah well you know
get yourself to a point where you find a
discipline that you like and then find
something that you now want to compete
in
and then get beat up and get punched in
the face and start to learn some other
skills right
yeah your face doesn't look like it's
been punched
well it's been punched by a girl you
know like you know like that you know
down here and down here sort of thing
right but you know the face could always
do with a slap every once in a while
from another man that you know slap some
sense in you
i've got a quick takeaway too so
remember if because it is natural you
will get those blue pill tendencies i
still get them every now and then i know
what they are they'll linger for a day
or two and then it's just a fleeting
emotion the minute you get another girl
in the rotation or you get a win or like
i'm really into like mexican redheads
now because they're rare and that's
something i haven't had before so when i
get one i'm like oh yeah like you know
i'm a [ __ ] again
um but in your case like remember when
you get that one nidis remember that
you've already had that girl before and
that was a girl you're able to get when
you got her so this is six months ago a
year ago a year and a half ago you
should be improving your smb so
at any time like in this moment i am the
worst i am going to be for the rest of
my life like i'm always improving my s
and v at least i'm trying to and girls
usually don't do much in
anything at all in terms of
self-improvement and we know like based
on really they just have to maintain
their beauty and a lot of times their
smv is going down so that gap is going
to widen a lot more as you get older so
just remind yourself that
that you're you're you're an um you're
an appreciating asset and she
is a deep depreciating asset and you're
able to get a girl like her before and
you should be able to get a girl better
at all times and the more the more you
get more reps and more wins you'll
realize the girls you get are higher
quality they're easier to get they're
easier to rein to maintain and retain
and then they're and then you just have
a much higher quality relationship
so just keep that in mind
all right man so sum it up chase
excellence not women thanks for hopping
in bro hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you